it's listen I've been out in the hallway
for a little while now I'm gonna be
honest with you guys it's a little too
happy in this room
you guys are like being it seems like
you like each other I saw this movie
though the mind is my name is joy really
feel right now movies fantastic say that
again it's fantastic time right it is
fantastic
I am curious though I love Eddie Murphy
I know you both love Eddie Murphy so I
guess the big question I want to know is
how much did you pay to be in the movie
I didn't pay I just slept with people I
use skills now I understand the left
Rudi's story the Dolomites and Rudy
story is unbelievable what as you were
preparing for this in making the movie
what really surprised you that maybe you
didn't know I you know I didn't know it
would not have occurred to me having
seen the movie Dolomites or the second
the second instalment Dolomites human
tornado it wouldn't have occurred to me
that that he worked that hard at honing
the pieces I can't I believe it's true
all the scenes we see Eddie in the
mirror and trying to work the lines out
and when he was writing down and
recording all the stuff from the hobos
and creating the character dolerite
it took you took a lot of care and a lot
of attention to do that when you see it
in the films it doesn't that doesn't
necessarily come across it wasn't
necessarily translated so to see it in
this movie in this kind of
do-it-yourself
step-by-step making of this kur of a
career of a coven Justin I won't say I
won't say take no for an answer career
that's what surprised me the most is how
much he prepared how dedicated he was to
creating the character of Dolomites the
artist perseverance yeah I didn't know
that you could mean I think I think I
was most surprised that at that time you
could make a movie without having the
studio involved yeah you know I didn't
know that was even feasible or possible
until you know this movie comes along
and tells that part of the story
and then also sweet sweet back with
sweet sweet bacteria Mario valve Melvin
Melvin one of the things about this film
that it's really dirty but it's really
sweet at the same time so can you sort
of talk about that aspect of it yeah the
thing is I think ultimately the the
veneer over the top is this raunchy
comedian but really what it is is it's a
pull yourself up by your bootstraps
person movie about perseverance about
that's what I think at the heart of it
at the kernel of it that's what the
movie is and that's why both things can
exist there's this kind of filigree on
the top of you know Boden eyes my name
and [ __ ] up motherfuckas is my game
but the fact that he wanted that he
wanted desperately to be known by the
world that's the thing that that line
that he says I want the world to know I
exist that's the crux of the film
everything else is wonderful but it's
it's the rest of its the planets that
are surrounding the Sun of the heart of
the movie mmm but we have to give some
credit to the weavers their director
Craig Brewer trying to editors and we're
able to take this obscure and you said
earlier inside baseball almost subject
matter and definitely raunchy definitely
not suited for some constituencies of
our our community and to weave it in
such a tapestry that you still are
comfortable with having it wrapped
around you and you can laugh and and you
can see the value of you can see the
artistry in their their skill set but
you can also see the value of
perseverance the heart is it but the
heart is a really big part of this story
the hardest it is going to be the most
pleasant surprising thing for viewers a
good director can take a bad script and
make it wonderful a great editor and a
director can take a bad script in a bad
movie and make it something magical my
last question for you or my last thing
for you Eddie Murphy I normally don't
ask about working with something like
clothes started but I've been a fan of
Eddie's my entire life so what was it
like working with him and maybe what
surprised you about working with him for
me
it was it was it was the what surprised
me about working with him is that calm
there's a real still waters run deep
feeling about Eddie which I was not
expecting expecting to be there more
energy between takes I was expecting
more energy and more of that between
take see he really conserves his energy
and stays here and then once here's
action boom he explodes and I was not
expecting that from him it was a I was
fascinated and pleasantly surprised hmm
his seriousness yeah yeah the
seriousness is which at which he
approaches the craft you know it's not
is definitely not a matter of just turn
the camera on and he goes back and does
whatever no he's he's clear he's
specific and calculating and inspired
thank you both so much thank yous and
grats on the movie it's fantastic call
thank you so much